nothing beats a great cake a sort of a
show-off trophy for party foods I'm
gonna make the most amazing flourless
chocolate cake but with a twist
first thing first make the camel flatten
the sugar never stir a camel rule number
one now keep the pan nice and flat I'm
gonna flavor this Carol with a little
bit of mint give it a little chop
sprinkle that into the caramel don't get
the caramel too dark just nice and light
a little teaspoon of oil onto the tray
and rub that in and then pour out your
camera
I was making a caramel sauce and I put
butter and cream into the camera but I
want this nice minted brittle running
through my cake boss McConnell comes
down on the tray I'm gonna make my cake
first melt good-quality dark chocolate
in a bain-marie
heating it directly in the pan would
destroy the cocoa fats always in a bowl
over boiling water in a mixing bowl
sugar two whole eggs and three egg yolks
whisk until beautifully light and creamy
and the color changes to a light yellow
the more you mix the eggs in the sugar a
lighter a texture in the center the
chocolate cake next melt some butter
into your warm dark chocolate and stir
put that really nice Sheen velvety rich
and tasting amazing add that to your
sugar and your eggs mmm now give her a
really good mix and when you're making
flowers desserts it really is important
to work harder incorporating air
especially with the yolks and the sugar
that natural height needs to take place
at the beginning know that it's like the
perfect chocolate ganache then separate
four egg whites into a bowl
[Music]
now make sure you've got two-thirds of
the way there with your whites and then
just sprinkle in just sugar almost like
a meringue and a firmer you make these
now more it will elevate your cake in
the oven
that's what you call a stiff peak in
with the whites before I start mixing
that I'll get my camera just start
breaking that up glass sheets of last
beautiful save some of your minty camel
shards for decoration and use a rolling
pin to break up the rest into small
pieces sprinkle that in so as we start
to slice that chocolate cake you'll come
across that nice crunch take your cake
tin make sure it's lined with a grease
proof paper on the bottom nicely greased
pour this in a few sharp taps on a hard
surface or rid your cake mixture of any
air pockets that could create holes in
your cake
sit down the other 180 after 35 minutes
my chocalate mint cake is cooked and
whilst it cools down I can whip up a
peppermint cream topping add sifted
icing sugar and a few drops of
peppermint extract to double cream and
whisk until it's just holding its shape
spoon your minty cream on top of the
cake leaving a small ball of free to
make it easier to cut for a cake that
can't fail to attract attention at your
party scatter over the remaining
cameramen shards